hello I'm Kelly Brennan director of the
National Library of Medicine and I'm
here to talk to you today about the NIH
research and education program that we
have underway here at the National
Library of Medicine this special program
referred to as an r25 training program
introduces promising young scholars
undergraduates and graduate students to
the field of biomedical informatics and
data science biomedical informatics and
data science is the fundamental core of
how we will discover Truth for health
over the next 50 years
the goal of the National Library of
medicine's R-25 program is to support
educational activities that encourage
talented undergraduate and master
students including those from groups
underrepresented in the biomedical
Behavioral Sciences to pursue further
training and careers in biomedical
informatics and data science
I am most excited to see this Innovative
program launched at the National Library
of Medicine it's frankly the most
exciting thing I've seen in the last
five years
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
as one of the 27 institutes at NIH the
National Library of Medicine supports
Innovative research and development and
biomedical informatics and data science
through the new r25 program nlm is
developing a new generation of
scientists capable of leading biomedical
informatics and data science research
into the future
this summer 12 universities are
participating in the inaugural cycle of
the program
we are super excited to be one of the 12
institutions uh being funded through the
National Library of Medicine for this
training and experiential learning in
biomedical informatics we all know that
it's very important for the next
generation of investigators to be
exposed to a wide variety of disciplines
they need a foundation in training and
experience in both life and physical
sciences as well as computational
mathematical engineering informatics
like many things associated with
Computing science is accelerating
exponentially so almost any scientific
field these days involves this big data
generation and now we started developing
this complex AI machine learning methods
to combine Big Data with these with
these Technologies so these training
programs I think provide a foundational
experiences for for young people and
help them see the utility of informatics
algorithms techniques and protocols and
give them an idea of what can be
accomplished and also ground them in
doing it with you know proper scientific
and statistical rigor
the NIH encourages all institutions to
diversify their student and faculty
populations to enhance the participation
of individuals from diverse groups
including those nationally
underrepresented in biomedical Clinical
and Behavioral and social science
research in addition the NIH encourages
individuals to identify with different
racial and ethnic groups as well as
those from socially and economically
disadvantaged backgrounds and
individuals with disabilities to
consider a career in biomedical sciences
and biomedical informatics
when you look at the composition of the
workforce in stem in general but let's
just say biomedical informatics it is
clear that we don't have a diversified
Workforce to meet the advances of the
21st century when Dr Boyce and I were
trying to set up a program we were
trying to count how many deaf and hard
of hearing students with biomedical
informatics or bioinformatics have a
degree you could just count it on your
fingers so the overall message is to
bring diversity in the field
through foundational skills building and
mentorship the nlm r25 program is
strengthening a diverse NIH supported
Workforce that will Foster scientific
innovation enhance Global
competitiveness and improve the quality
of research
my dream job is to bridge Healthcare
Systems along with health informatics
especially coming from a place where you
get to see
Health determine its affect the health
risks in today's world a lot of it comes
from environmental factors external
factors and that's something I want to
bring more advocacy to especially using
health informatics for me to have those
skills especially being a female I
believe that you can Bridge Hands-On
health care experience and then the
world of data science and technology and
that's something that I would like to
take part in
part of making data available to so many
different audiences is really building
that scaffolding that infrastructure for
people to find data and then ultimately
make use of it MLM has been involved in
Data before data science was even really
a term we have the national Center for
biotechnology information which is a
really incredible data resource for
people that are working with biomedical
data of all different types and we have
a lot of other resources that we make
available like PubMed to provide access
to the literature so really we have been
involved in making information and data
available to people for a long time
a lot of these tools that are we're
going to be teaching them you know how
to look for genomic sequences or how to
do you know data visualization or things
like that those are the tools and skills
that are required by the market and I
think by giving them through this
program and also you know especially
since it's from the National Library of
Medicine where we use a lot of their
Tools in our classrooms I think it will
be very good for them to kind of get
exposure to some in-depth skills that
are required by the field now
who are in this
in this Mission from us we have
computerized clinical records and all of
these different data sources that if we
could combine them and figure out you
know what are the best forms of analysis
we can really accelerate the speed of
biomedical discovery
so we're talking about artificial
intelligence machine learning natural
language processing all of these ways of
collecting analyzing data we need to
have the prepared Workforce
each student will have a research
faculty mentor to work one-on-one this
is very very important because many
times you start a graduate level career
and you take courses but it takes a
while until you find the right mentor
and you have so many faculty that you're
going to be exposed to and you know that
that individual that you identify were
food identifies you it's going to be
extremely important not only for your
graduate career but also as you move
into your career further I owe
everything I am to my mentors today my
you know especially my scientific career
I myself have trained over 150 people
and they all keep in touch with me and
I'm so happy to see them really do well
when they go into you know top positions
and they get tenure track positions or
they start their own companies so to me
that is the most rewarding aspect of it
is the human interaction paying what was
paid to me forward to all these students
the impact of this program
I see it as going far beyond education
and career decision of the students that
will participate it will really create
that awareness that's so needed in
biomedical informatics in public health
informatics and data science it it will
really emphasize and take advantage of
the great spirit of information sharing
that it's so needed today